[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to
leia inspired powered by icon plus and
sponsored by cakewallet
if you don't know cakewallet are super
cool open source
monero mobile wallet which i use so
totally recommend them you can check
them out on twitter it's just cakewallet
but since this is sponsored and powered
by iphone plus i want to give you guys a
really quick icon news announcement
it's quite cool so icon is actually
helping with the fight against covert 19
um as icons my id cover tracking system
gets adopted by south korea's tourist
hotspot jeju island
quite interesting since borders are
starting to open up again
so back to leia inspired i have a really
interesting guest today he's a fighter
and i'm super into the wrestling i don't
think he knows this um he's into crypto
i'm a bitcoiner it is
none other than ben askren ben welcome
to the program how you doing what's
up uh i'm doing great i had a busy
morning i've already been on one podcast
i had a little business card for us and
hopped on and i'm excited
yeah it's great to have you so if you
didn't know i'm actually quite a huge
fan of wrestling um i've kind of like
grown up
with like my brothers forcing me to
wrestle watching you already
watching wwe i know we've not spoken
about this but it's true
okay i thought wrestling wasn't so
not wwe but wrestling i thought
yesterday wasn't all that popular
in the uk um i feel like wrestling's
bigger in the states right
just because everything's sort of
everything's bigger in texas and
everything's just bigger in the states
right
um but no it is um and i saw this week
you were on the phones with chuckleh so
what the hell is that
tell me uh well you know you're the
first person to actually ask me about it
um is that me or you
well oh i can't hear feedback i don't
know let me check in the comments if
anyone's
okay okay yeah so um no this guy nick
cohn reached out to me we had kind of
went back and forth uh about another
subject
email and then uh he said hey would you
want to talk to triple h i said sure
and then i asked my buddy who who nick
khan was he's like oh man
that guy he's a really big deal and so i
looked nick up
nick's a huge deal which he was very
humble because he didn't bring up the
fact that he was such a big deal
yeah um and then yeah i got the phone
with triple h and i i'm actually i'm
only 12 days out for my hip surgery
right now
um you know so i told him hey you know i
got hip surgery in 12 days they said
okay
well after you start feeling better from
the hip surgery
then uh you know hit us up and uh he
wants to fly me down and
i don't think i want to be a full-time
wwe guy
listen i'm i'm entertained by it
i am i wouldn't say a huge fan but i'm a
fan and so you know i would i might i
would enjoy doing something with them
i'm not sure
what that's going to look like well in
what capacity would you want to do
something with them because
wwe is super showbiz i feel like you
kind of have that showbiz vibe
um you know all about like the you know
big on the talk and all that stuff so i
feel like it could work so in what
capacity would it suit you
well i mean just that what i think about
i was like i really enjoy my life the
way it is
um you know i have my podcast i have my
my brother and i own five wrestling
academies together and
i coach there all the time and i really
enjoy that
so you know it's like if it was old
school wrestling where you got to travel
five days a week like no
there's no way i got three young kids
that's just not happening um
but you know if it was like hey show up
twice a month or something like that
sure yeah well that sounds like fun
maybe i could do that so
i don't know like i said i don't know
what that's going to look like you know
we didn't get two we had a nice fun
conversation for 20 minutes
um and you know i said we would follow
up after the hip surgery
nice how are you feeling after you hit
surgery no no it's in 12 days
ah it's in 12 days i'm sorry okay okay
and
how are you expecting to fight again can
we expect anything coming up
or like months after that or are you
sort of just
yeah i i don't think i don't think i'm
gonna fight i think it's highly unlikely
um but i hopefully i'll be feeling
better than i felt in quite a long time
because it's uh
yeah i mean it's worse now than it's
ever been it just keeps getting worse
and worse or worse so
like i'm like oh 12 days like i was
showing a move last night at the
wrestling academy and i
freaking like went down in pain it was
it was
it was bad so yes i'm i'm looking
forward to
feeling better yeah no i'm sure and this
is kind of what i want to get into
because you know you've
put yourself in the ring i guess like i
could say and you've had you know
plenty of fights um so we'll we'll get
to that but
this week you did launch um a mindset
course so firstly congratulations to
that that's really exciting
that's um totally fits in with his vibe
so that's really cool um
and a weird mindset you know getting in
the ring having i guess
like you know the kicked out of you
and all that basically how do you do
that right like how do you get back in
the ring again
um especially after a loss like how do
you do that what is
what is that mindset that you need to be
able to
get back in again basically yeah well so
i mean that
my course is on failure or dealing with
adversity kind of they're right i think
they're kind of the same thing ish
so here's my stories like i've you know
so i played a lot of sports
growing up but wrestling was kind of
what was the one i liked the most
and um i also wasn't very good so i took
a lot of l's right i i was i
did not have a lot of success and so i
had to learn how to bounce back and you
know i think that's one of the best
things that wrestling teaches kids that
from a young age
it is one-on-one like when you lose you
can't say oh it was my teammate's fault
it was the coach's fault for a bad
strategy no it's like
you go out there you shake their hand
you wrestle you win or lose and you take
ownership of that and so from a young
age i learned how to deal with that and
then you know
as i got better and better and better
it's not like the losses stopped right
they still kept happening
um and so you learn how to bounce back
and you know that's something that i
think a lot of people
maybe don't necessarily have to feel a
lot in their life because they don't
compete in a one-on-one sport
um and i feel like you know where it
really stuck out to a lot of people was
after the george fight i mean i was 19-0
i didn't lose in
uh nearly a decade of mixed martial arts
and i i lost and
to me it was like okay right i've lost
100 other times in my life whatever i'm
the same
i'm the same guy july 7th as i was july
5th i'm going to get back up and i'm
going to keep moving forward i mean
that definitely wasn't ideal what
happened but it's also not going to stop
me from going where i want to go
yeah no 100 you have to just keep going
but i think what's really interesting
and i think this sort of
sort of stretches outside of fighting
it's just kind of one of those things
where
um everybody knows what's coming up
everybody knows
there's a fight or even you know if
somebody knows you're starting a new job
somebody knows you're starting something
new you're doing something
you big it up um i guess it's part of
like the showbiz vibe you big it up you
say this is happening
um and then it doesn't go to plan like
the jorge masbidel fight
so how do you then deal with that
afterwards
um well so here that's that's humanity i
was actually i just brought this up
on monday that's an aerial show on
monday with daniel cormier
it's like dude you could you could be as
good as you want in life but you can
accomplish
oh yeah i was 19-0 right daniel cormier
won multiple ufc titles was the olympics
multiple times
and people still want to call him a
bridesmaid or a failure and it's like
dude that was a dude that accomplished
more than 99.9999 right
i mean we're talking about the highest
percentile if people still come on
failure
that's humanity right i am literally not
worried at all
about that because you literally you
can't if you are worried about that
that's going to prevent you from doing
something that you want to do
especially the first the first module in
my course is all about
there's a lot of people who never start
something because they're worried about
the
end result they don't start because
they're worried about what the end
result is it drives yourself
even if even if you started mma or
wrestling and you became as successful
as daniel cormier which again is like
the highest percentile and you fail a
couple times people are going to try to
call you a failure
right that's just what happens so you
have to accept that that is part of the
deal
when you start something you are not
going to be
flawless in your execution of it you are
going to fail you're going to have
struggle and that's fine because that's
part of it
and it's funny right because the people
that scream failure or the people that
sort of laugh at you
are the ones sitting in their comfort
zone too afraid to even do anything
right
well and lots of times it's because
that's what they think about right
that's where their mind is so that they
can't let themselves out because
you know when they're saying daniel
cormier you suck you know what when
they're thinking about going do
something they're saying well you can't
go do that because you suck they're
literally talking to themselves saying
no you're gonna you're gonna fail
people are gonna make fun of you you're
going to get embarrassed you're going to
look bad
they're literally having that self-talk
that's coming through themselves so
you know like a lot of people say do i
hate my trolls no no
actually a lot of times i kind of feel
bad for them right they need something
oh okay
i like this this is very garyvee
seriously but they need someone in their
life to give them a hug they need
someone in their life to tell them they
can do it
and you know when people ask me about
the wrestling academy it's like
the thing i get most out of the
wrestling academies
there's a lot of kids in their life and
some of them have great parents some
other great teachers but some of them
have no one in their life that tells
them
look i'm gonna look you in the eyes and
i'm gonna tell you you can do it
and sometimes sometimes i'm telling you
stop being a baby you can do it
sometimes i'm telling you
that's okay you failed you can do it but
i'm going to tell you you can do it
i'm going to tell you that and i'm
inspired yeah
i love that i love that yeah and that's
so important so
when you can finally get a kid to
believe in himself that is a really
powerful thing because
and you know when you think of the one
side of it like some kids have such
parents
that they feel like they can't ever go
try anything because
their parents tell them you suck you're
stupid you're not good enough like
that's that's that's
freaking depressing i totally agree with
you i think you know
just for someone just to tell you that
you can do something is the most
powerful thing i know it's really cliche
but it's so true when someone says sort
of like
um you know whether you believe you can
or you can't you're right and i wasn't
actually going to go into this but i
kind of just want to touch on it so
i want to know your thoughts on the
education system then right because it
doesn't
teach us i know i wasn't going to go
into it but like you said you know you
did wrestling as a kid
so it was kind of like that one to one
you felt that loss so you sort of were
able to build that um
relationship with failure so what
happens if someone didn't do that sport
and they literally rely
on the education system to give them
that strength
yeah well i mean so i in addition i did
have good coaches also right i had some
really good coaches when i was younger
growing up who they did the same thing
to me right they
they they helped me bounce back from
losses they told me i could do it they
you know
they supported me uh my parents were
also very supportive right so i had
i had good people around me and i'm
thankful that that was the case because
obviously helped me become who i am
um yeah i mean i'm not an expert on
education system and i don't know if
it's the exact same in england but i
know i was in america i
i would say it wasn't really a great fit
for me because i'm kind of like free
spirit wanna do my own thing and it's
more like
um you know here's the rules you stay
within it and you know i wasn't um
i wasn't a bad student because i was
always smart enough to get by
but i wasn't an excellent student either
because i just
wasn't as interested in the subject
matter as i needed to be to be
successful
i was more obsessed with wrestling or
things on the side
that's what i was really obsessed about
uh oh she went away are we still
we're still hello hello are we live can
you hear me
i think we might ben can you i don't
know what happened
that's a shame i feel like you're back
i'm back okay guys well
we've still got our viewers say thanks
guys for sticking around so wait you
were literally just about to say
something
about the education system you're not an
expert on it but
oh okay that's give me a very something
yeah
um i was just saying it didn't fit me
perfectly i wasn't um
a terrible student but i wasn't a great
student either because i wasn't
interested enough in the subject matter
and you know had i had more
freedom to kind of explore what uh
excited me more
um then i probably would have uh um you
know i would have
i would have excelled even more yeah and
i totally agree with you i think there's
a massive issue right now
with the education system i think so
that's why we will sort of start
laughing about it because there is a
lack of sort of
motivation mindset and that's why we
have people like yourself bringing out
these courses so you're also working as
a bit of a coach
so explain to me what do you teach what
are like your i guess like your
five main key rules that you would say
to somebody when it comes to sort of
tackling life adversity
um failure and so on yeah um
hmm that's that's interesting i don't
know if i have five key rules or
anything
you can have three it's okay as many as
i want
i think uh so i i think one of the
biggest things that i
that i help my kids with and this is you
know
again go back to the success field or
the the deal and failure course
is like i don't necessarily put things
in the same dynamics a lot of people do
so for example
when a kid goes to wrestle it's like all
i want right now is
your best effort if you give me your
best effort i'm going to be able to help
you do the rest um as opposed to like i
want you to win
like obviously if you win that's great
but what i really want is your best
effort
when we're practice give me your best
effort and if we can do those things
i'll take care of the rest right i'll
worry about your technique
i'll worry about everything else give
you give me your best effort and that's
kind of the biggest thing that we really
focus on
a lot i like that i like that and i
think you know it takes the pressure off
kids
um you know making it all about the win
all about the failure
it's all about just putting your best in
believing that you can and then sort of
going from there
um so yeah totally with you but you said
that you wouldn't necessarily
um get back in and fight properly again
so i guess sort of
looking back what would you say um
is the main thing that you've learned
throughout all of this
oh my god well the title is called layer
inspired you could have expected
anything less give me a book
on that um man i you know i think it
would go again go back to the failure
course and i
i would say uh for for me it's like
just keep moving forward there's gonna
be struggle there's going to be failure
that's good for you that teaches you
um and that's going to make you better
at whatever you do so you know for
example right
um like we launched the course uh
you would i'd like to sell a million
dollars in the first week sure did we
sell a million dollars no
okay well there's there's room for
improvement okay how did you know
this is the first course i've released
how do we do it i mean that was that was
what my meeting was right before this we
yeah sat down and and so it's and that's
everything right
you're not you're not going to knock it
out of the park you're not going to be
flawless
on the first try ever ever at anything
right
um and so just how do you get better how
do you deal with diversity
and that's kind of probably the biggest
thing you know so we'll just say combat
sports right wrestling and mma because
that's something i've done
uh almost the entirety of my life you
know how do you bounce back from things
gemini regrets in uh the career
i don't have any regrets i i love that
yeah well you know it's one of those
things where and this is kind of again
thought process
but um you can't really change the past
right you can learn from the past so
take things that happen
learn from them but you can't change it
and and so this is again
and then if we go into performance and
so i've been doing mental monday
what i call mental mondays on my social
media for about five years
where i take questions right someone
they dm me questions and i answer them
um and the the literally the number one
most asked thing but and it's not it's
not even close right there's a lot of
different versions of it but essentially
is
my kid get in mostly wrestling my
audience my kid gets to the big match
and they fail in the big match
okay yeah or right so some version of
that why does that happen
and yeah for most people that happens
because they're they're thinking about
the wrong
things right so and we're trying to
write really specifically
performing or competing so performing
giving a speech right
doing a podcast would be essentially a
performance right okay um any of those
things where you actually have to be in
the moment
think about things that don't matter
right right now if you're
really worried about what people on
twitter are thinking of you
you're not gonna do a good job
podcasting you're not going to be in it
right if you're in a wrestling match
and you're thinking about the crowd well
i should be thinking about how i pin the
guy not
the crowd if i'm really if i'm really
genuinely thinking about the crowd i'm
not going to do
the activity really well and and so i
think that is like
man if people can actually understand
that if they can really
get that and then obviously there's
understanding and there's being really
good at right
there's practicing and there's being
really key how do i key in
on this moment what i'm doing right now
if you could do that really really well
that's going to make
people so much better my gosh you're so
right
and i think you know everything we do in
public like right now
is a performance so it's true if you
think about if you're focused on what
people are thinking about you on twitter
then you're actually gonna
trash your performance entirely because
like you said you're not thinking about
getting you know what you need to get
out or pinning the guy or whatever it is
um so you are
quite big into crypto so that's
obviously how we got connected
so this is really cool because it's
really unique
um crypto is super niche and i think
it's very different to hear people
outside of this crazy bubble
and have taken an interest in it so take
us from the beginning how the hell did
you hear about crypto
and what was like that red pill moment
like why weren't you just like ah
bitcoins like
what would i really sold it for you well
i would say i was kind of red pill
before
uh crypto um i i think you know like
we have the pot as my podcast right
there yeah
um i think it is reading the ron paul
and understanding you know
really what it is always wrong isn't it
so we've done i think we've got 37
episodes of funky crypto podcast so
that's like you know it's it's such a
crypto show for beginners and one of our
main questions is how did you get into
it
i would say it's 50 minimum 50 ron paul
people
like literally like if ron paul knows
how many people he read pilled he should
be
proud of himself i mean that's like one
of the most um
yeah he is such a convincing thinker but
so when i i was open to it so i
i could tell you literally exactly the
moment um
my buddy lives in australia i fought in
shanghai
he um he flew with he flew to me he flew
to a bunch of my fights because he lived
on he's from america but he lives in
australia
so whenever i go to asia a lot of times
he would fly to meet me
and um he said he had a spreadsheet out
it was
it was i think august 28th of 2017 so
right right before you know
it kind of as around getting started
it's very decent
you know hey you need to get into this
and it literally took me five minutes i
said oh
oh oh i i got it right i i totally get
it but why what did you hear from ron
paul that you were like oh okay
now that makes sense like what the hell
did he say to you just i mean like i
think a lot of people
um think that the dollar is the only
important thing in the world the only
important source of value in the world
and once you realize that
kind of anything can be money and over
the course of history a lot of
um a lot of things have been money and
then that
that good money has very specific
properties
and i think bitcoin kind of meets all
those criteria and obviously this isn't
a stranger talking to me right this is a
guy who i trust who i know
who knows me and so we can have we can
get down to the nitty-gritty of the
conversation really quickly
um and then i think i remember is like i
literally bought quit like that day i'm
like all right
freaking logged me out me on him
did you
buy what did you buy um i don't so
listen that we
i really wish i would have bought all
bitcoin at that point i i could tell you
yeah
you bought coins oh yeah so much i could
tell you i'll
so over the course of that
it was really annoying because in the
beginning they would only let you buy
like i would say my limit was like five
grand a week or something when
oh wow where were you buying from i
don't even know
i don't even recall at this point in
time this is a lot i bought a
bunch of erc 20 tokens also
so i got my limit bumped up pretty
quickly so i think i spent 50 grand
within
four to six weeks
and my 50 grand went to um about 150
grand
within the next say eight to 12 weeks
right like that that end of 2017 was
wild
and then i got the the you know right i
got to do deal with the tough part of it
so then my 150 grand ish went to
like 25. you took no profit
you took no profit i didn't think any i
talked i talked openly about that on the
john
you know i'm with john it's like the one
that was the biggest winner
in that in that series i bought pillar
token
uh they're still around they actually
their products actually relatively good
i just i've just held everything
but i think i bought for a roughly 10
cents and i think that their their token
went to a dollar fifty so 15x so i went
from like
i think i bought like three grand and it
was worth like ended up being worth 50
grand
and i that i probably should have sold
at 50 grand
uh you know not now it's worth like uh
1500 or something something to that
um yeah so you know i got to explain
within a really short
time window i got to experience the the
mania
and then the crash so i got to see it
all um
but you know i bought in because i
believed in the concept of
bitcoin well that that's why i bought in
and so you know i talked john about this
it's like well i know there's gonna be a
run-up coming
and i'm gonna i think i'm gonna have a
really hard time selling because i
believe in the long-term vision of sound
money and
it's not just about making money for me
it's it's about that
i literally think this is the future
yeah and i think that's kind of like
a sort of a dichotomy right now between
bitcoin is because
some people are in it for the profits
right so they're like okay you've got to
know when the top is take it for
you know get your profits at the top but
there's also an issue because people
like hang on if you really believe
in this new revolution if you believe in
sort of like overtiming the banksters as
they say
then you wouldn't sell at all right yes
because you you
why would you sort of buy into the banks
and fiat and so on
by gaining your profits yes
which is what you won't you won't see
you sort of i agree i mean
so right then the pushback would be then
and i i don't know where i
fall yet um the pushback would be well
you know you could sell when it when it
goes to mania you sell
and then you buy back more uh obviously
that would be the push back and i
don't know i said
i don't know maybe i'll just like you
know there's a lot of really good
products like i said block five they
sponsored us for a while
uh yeah you know maybe uh i put my
crypto in there and or
interest or something so so that way i
don't have to sell it
it's still mine but i'm making money off
it maybe i do that
um yeah i gotta figure out exactly what
i'm gonna do because i'm not sure
there's like too many options right now
with defy and this and that
it's crazy so how do you then do you
ever try to sort of like
bring crypto to your sort of colleague
fighters
i don't know like you're on the phone to
triple h you ever like yo triple h have
you seen bitcoin like
it's like making new all-time highs this
year like are you
is that happening or yeah um i mean you
know what i think fighters
dana white you know dana white like let
me tell you
one of the other guys who's really high
up in the ufc calls me frequently about
bitcoin it's really funny um because one
time
this guy called me he's you know he's
talking and he's talking about bitcoin
what about this or what about that when
we started having bitcoin and then you
know we've been talking about 10 minutes
i'm like
did you like did you just call me to
talk about bitcoin or did you call me
like
he's like oh yeah i'm supposed to offer
you a fight oh my god that's brilliant
i'm like oh that's why you called me and
that you know so long story i'm not
gonna tell you what the fight was or
anything but yeah
so then um but it was really funny
because he called and started talking
about bitcoin for a while and then
you know eventually i'm like did you
really just call just to talk about
bitcoin
um so yeah i mean i think uh you know my
the way i view
uh my role in this is i'm not like a
super crypto expert i'm not as smart as
a lot of these guys they're really
brilliant um i think i understand the
basics and i understand the value
proposition
and so i think my role is to um kind of
put a few thoughts out there for people
and then
some people will be interested and you
never know what's going to click with
some people to make them say
oh okay well well let me look more into
that right
and then hopefully that you know they
hear me and john talking on a low level
about some things and maybe some clips
them and then maybe they start digging
for themselves right
because you never want to force anyone's
thoughts into
you know taking a risk with their money
you want them to want to do that
themselves you want them to
um understand what sound money is why
bitcoin has a really good value
proposition you want them to get that
for themselves and then go obviously act
on that
yeah i'm totally with you because i
think i i don't know if you saw
um but did you remember when jk rowling
asked
what is bitcoin on twitter were you
there for that yeah
and okay so it was just like a
storm and a her just running at her like
you need bitcoin you gotta get it now
this is how you get like
let me teach you you know suddenly
everyone was like super charitable with
their bitcoin
um and i think sort of like things like
that would scare people away right
sort of saying you need to have it
you've got to buy it because i think
with anything
outside of bitcoin whenever anyone's
trying to tell you what to do with your
money
it's off-putting you gotta you get your
walls up don't you
um yeah and then obviously there's just
like uh
i mean that's kind of like anything in
life right when people come out yeah
you kind of pull back you know i mean
that that's that's
really anything yeah i'm totally with
you so then
um okay so you've obviously got a huge
um
audience mainly wrestling i guess sort
of audience
so if you had to um no i wouldn't give
you okay i'm not gonna put the pressure
on you and tell you to redraw them but
if you
had to try oh yeah go on
how would you how would you rad build
them give us like your bitcoin quick
elevator pitch on bitcoin or on life
uh we'll do two let's do bitcoin first
well did it like did epstein kill
himself you know
what do you think and actually kill
himself was i've got to do a bitcoin
tell me
what has to do with red pilling it
doesn't matter
do you think he did actually you're
right i stand corrected do i oh um
no i don't think he killed himself no
i'm a
no he didn't kill um yeah so i i
think
well i i sorry you know what i think
that goes in with the red pill and the
bitcoin i think
it does it goes in with um you know some
people
literally think the federal government
is and this you know obviously we're in
different countries but they think it's
all knowing
it's all seeing and they think it has
the best monetary policy ever and
they're always looking out
uh for your best interest at all times
and i think once you realize
uh maybe the federal government is not
looking out for my best interest
maybe i should take some of this uh take
some initiative and take this into my
own hands
um you know that lots of times i think
then leads you to being more open to
oh wait the federal gov the federal
reserve is not actually
owned by the us government it's actually
owned by other people oh really
um you know so i think that's kind of
like you know once you understand those
things i think they go kind of hand in
hand
and then it's kind of like a massive um
scam
that um they don't tell us this right
like if we go back to school in
education that we know nothing about
monetary policy we know nothing
um about what the dollar is supposedly
backed by and so on right
and it's so funny because everyone in
crypto constantly like scream scam but
like to me the biggest scam in life is
just sort of
the education system and the lack of
knowledge that it teaches us basically
or the lack of um
sort of motivation to be an individual
thinker and think things for yourself
and so on
so if you had to give um a kind of
red pill then for life so that was like
that was bitcoin if you had to rattle
someone on life and power
and you know how you get in the ring all
the time and you know get back in there
get kicked and punched and hurt and
bruised and now you need an operation
how do you do it what would you say i
don't so i don't think mo i don't even
try to rip till most people because
they're not really ready they don't want
it do they they don't want it
you know they want it they want to
listen to what what's your guys main
news station like you know everyone
who's listening to what fox news they're
cnns tell them and they want to
just accept that to be complete and
total reality they don't want to
question
anything they want to think that the
dollar is all knowing we're all seeing
and that's where they want to live their
life and listen that's listen i'm not
going to judge you if that's what you
want from your life that's that's fine
and i hope you do really well and i hope
you live a great life and
but that's not where i'm at i'm not i
want i kind of want to question
everything i want to dig deep i want to
turn over every stone
i want to know as much as i can know i
want to be inquisitive
um and that's kind of you just led me to
another question then i have to ask you
i have to ask you do you know what it is
or not do you know what i'm going to ask
you next no i have no idea
you don't have no idea i'm gonna ask
about about coronavirus i just have to
ask you
so if you're questioning everything
firstly
yeah okay so let's talk a little bit
about that then so how do you
what do you think is going on
particularly in america such a hard one
yeah i just said like particularly in
america we've seen how they've sort of
like bumped up the
death numbers so it's like if somebody
dies of a heart attack but like i don't
know
they might have had covert they may not
have had covert but like yeah i will
just put them on the covered list
that's kind of concerning you know that
sort of inflates
and creates um sort of unnecessary
hysteria so
i'll open the floor to you yeah you know
what
corona it's been interesting because i i
i haven't taken in the beginning i i was
legit scared i watched a bunch of videos
from china in like february
i'm like oh damn like i i didn't leave
my house for 14 days
i was like oh no way that's hilarious
yeah i was very i love that um i'm sorry
and now as it's went on
longer it seems to not be as big of a
deal and
then the the man it is getting
politicized one thousand percent it's so
politicized
it's annoying as um and so
for me i i'm struggling with it
because i want to respect people's fee
right even if someone has a fear of
something and it's not
it's not tied to reality i kind of want
to respect their space
right at the same time my wrestling
academy's been open since june 1st we've
had hundreds of kids we've done camps
we've had kids come from all over the
country
we've had no proliferation whatsoever of
any coronavirus we've had a couple kids
get it from
other places then they call and tell us
hey i had this
i haven't been in since whatever day
okay cool
you know what even though they haven't
been in since last tuesday i'm gonna go
tell
whoever you're with the day before that
just in case and we've had
zero issue whatsoever uh people don't
seem to be even
concerned in the slightest bit so i'm
having a hard time
you know my reality of what i see every
single day in the wrestling academy and
wrestling's about as close as you're
gonna get to a person um and then
the reality of what people are trying to
tell me to be worried about and what i
see on tv
they don't match up so i'm really
struggling with that i
think um i mean i'm hoping that it's
it's starting to wind down here in
america the numbers have been declining
for five weeks
now but yeah it has been gross how much
things have been
politicized and you know and this is
listen both people are
both sides are at fault right and
america is very two parties right now
people are trying to to run whatever
angle they want that they think
helps them the most politically as
opposed to just saying
here's our problem because it is
definitely a real thing and whether
you know whether you're right it says i
think i'll i'll look right now so i
don't misspeak
uh okay hold on but it says right now in
america it has killed
oh gd the website's being slow uh sorry
i think 170 000 ish we'll say
okay okay america has killed 176 000. so
whether the number is
176 000 or maybe they've inflated it's
000 right maybe it's a little larger um
that's still quite a few people and you
don't want to
you don't want to um make those
livestreams meaningless oh it's just 120
000 people but then at the same time on
the other side it's like well a lot of
people die
of the flu and people die of obesity and
people die of car accidents
so it's like you can't you know we live
in a world where you can't totally put
yourself in a bubble either
so it's no and yeah and we yeah it is
and we've seen actually how it's had
negative effects keeping people
locked down whether that be because you
know in london for example that's where
i'm based at the moment um
a lot of people live in tiny little
townhouses and they have no garden
people live on their own they're
completely isolated
the mental health implications not being
able to work out not being able to see
family
and pressure on relationships almost has
caused
a lot more havoc and sort of um people
sort of didn't expect it to go so
so badly when they sort of decided to
keep us all locked down basically
um so vaccine or no vaccine
well i've never taken a flu shot and i
really i don't want anything to be
mandated absolutely not i mean that that
would be
an infringement on our freedoms um
i go both yeah though because then it's
also like well there were these really
bad diseases a long time ago that they
created vaccines for and that has made
the world
a significantly better place i think
we'd say um
so but then there's the you know in
america they have the vaccine courts
where they're held non-liable for
anything
so a man i think it's like an issue that
i wish would be more transparent and
more
open for people not in this world but
it's not
yeah it's not so i'm not in this world
yes what about masks then masks like you
said you're all about freedom so
uh so i'm not saying do you think they
no i'm not saying should people wear
them
i'm saying do you think they should be
mandatory and you know
you know actual criminal fines for not
wearing one
i would say so i would say man not
mandatory right
i would say if a certain business wants
to do that because uh that's their
beliefs i think they
probably have the right to do so um
you know and but then i also go back to
right i
i don't i don't mean to be playing the
fence but i kind of am and i'm playing
defense because i don't know what the
right answer is and i'm i think i'm
i guess humble enough to admit that you
know like when you go to i try i spend a
lot of time in asia
um okay when i fought there for four
years exclusively
a lot of people there wear masks
especially when you're on a plane in
asia
man i would say 60 of people wear masks
right it's it's a really high number
and so you know that's kind of already a
part of their everyday life and you know
some of them have had better success
than america or the european countries
um but then you'd also say well their
obesity rates are lower their life
expectancies are longer they're a little
healthier
yeah so you know yeah no i hate you i
hear you i think for me just like the
biggest concern is
um a lot of the a lot of the laws that
have been put in
um are very much just for the short term
but i think
it's very hard to um sort of
undo those laws right i think i was
speaking to somebody recently and they
told me about a lot of
so this was actually before my time well
no it's not for my time when 9 11
happened
um all these new security laws came into
place now i don't remember
life flying i must have been like five
years old so i don't remember
what it was like from like i'm 24. oh my
god i'm 24. yeah yeah yeah yeah
in high school and that happened yeah so
what's 17
yeah no i'm 24. so i was too young to
remember what life was
like flying um before 9 11. but i
understand that apparently there weren't
all those security measures
and now they haven't taken them back so
what happens you know um with the social
distancing thing like there's never
going to be a moment whereby
corona's finished do you know what i
mean really
oh no doctor it's got to go away
sometime doesn't it yeah but yeah but a
gradual go away it's not going to be
like we wake up one day it's not like
taking like antibiotics and then like
done you're fine you're healed
it seems to be like a slow slow gradual
you know
going away which sort of means like when
do we loosen these restrictions like
should we just keep them a little bit
longer in case
you know should we just keep this social
distancing precautions in place because
you know
there's still a little bit of corona
lingering
you know if we give if we give them a
bet when do we
they take a mile and keep it yeah i i i
don't know i think that's what a lot of
people are worried about
i don't know that that's gonna be
reality and i don't want to say that is
until
till we get there so um yeah but that
man that's again a
really really tough one for sure ben
gone give us your final thoughts then
final thoughts on yeah let me see if i
can put you on full screen
i should know how to do that let's let's
give it a go oh that's me hey guys
there we go that's you go on ben give us
your final thoughts final thoughts i
appreciate you having me on um i love
that you're trying to put crypto out
there i think that's going to give
people more freedom in their everyday
lives and then you know i guess kind of
like i said
uh go to you can check out my website
ben asking.com i just made a course on
uh deal with failure and adversity that
i think is really good and
um i really love being able to help
people
accomplish more in life and tell them
they can do it because i think that's a
strong message that they're not always
getting from a lot of different people
that's beautiful let's make it back
there we go ben thank you so much i want
to say thank you to you and say thank
you to cakewallet our sponsors and icon
plus for powering it
guys over and out we will see you all
soon next week
yeah peace